so as we get into night of the owls
because quarter the owls was so long ago
and because DC has released information
on the organization since my last video
what I want to do here is create this
sort of backstory with the information
we're given in order to get you all up
to snuff and provide you with a solid
understanding of what's going on so the
earliest history of the court of owls
comes to us in Catwoman issue number
nine depicting the group operating in
Gotham City in 1659 what we're not
really given any context regarding what
the group was doing at the time we can
probably get away with assuming that
much like their modern-day counterparts
during this era the court of owls worked
to control the city of Gotham the
focusing more on an agent of the court
referred to as the talent the story
shows us that the town had been assigned
to kill a member of the city for unknown
reasons however the Talon team that
killing an unarmed man was dishonorable
and so the talent provided him with a
dagger and allowed him to flee for his
life he catching up to the man and
killing him the nature of the court is
revealed when we learned that the Talon
was spotted by several soldiers and an
officer requiring him to kill them all
in order to ensure the courts secrecy
following this we pick up with Batman
and Robin issue number twenty three
point two continuing to provide glimpses
into the history of the court this story
follows the actions of a man named Henry
in 1891 because a court is a highly
secretive organization operating out of
an exclusive residence called the harbor
house club but has eyes and ears all
throughout the city and forming them of
the goings-on where Henry photographed
the group but lacks any concern
regarding the dangerous nature of the
court and links it will go to to
maintain it to secrecy
his wife seems to understand the danger
while her fear is most likely tied
directly into the nursery ROM of the
court of owls
she nonetheless begs Henry not to
publish his photograph or let anyone
know what he saw and tending to head to
Philadelphia to cash in his photo and
run an expose in order to provide
himself and his wife with the money
needed to start a new life as he
prepares aboard the train he suddenly
sees around the neck by a noose and hung
to die in addition to this while Henry
hangs a man sneaks up behind his wife
and suffocates her with the next day's
newspaper depicting the incident as a
murder-suicide now jump me in 1922 as
the last part of our history we pick up
with Batman's great-grandfather
a man named Allen Wayne running through
the street seeking help from anyone who
will listen Colin Wayne eventually comes
upon two police officers considering em
to have lost his mind as he babbles on
about owls roosting in the thirteenth
floor of various buildings when the
officers turn around to discuss what to
do with Allen he simply falls or
vanishes into a manhole with no one
really having any idea what it was it
happened to him
Nats transitioning to the Talon this
story is actually far more
straightforward what Scott Snyder and
Greg Capullo do here is retcon a bit of
dick Grayson's history where initially
Dick Grayson was the son of acrobats
from Haley's circus who were killed by a
monster in court of owls snyder caputo
established that Haley's family line had
been running the circus for generations
and operated as an arm of the court of
the Owls as it's explained every ten
years the circus would present their
most talented children to the court of
owls who in turn would select one child
to become a talent from here one of the
teeth would receive a filling composed
of electrum which was a metal made of
copper and silver as a part of the
child's tooth the election would
basically seep into the body and become
a part of their DNA and so by the time
they became an adult and died whether
from natural causes or something else
the court would be able to use the metal
to effectively bring them back to life
as a being with peak physical training
with the effects of electromagnetic heal
the Talon serves as the perfect assassin
and using some kind of freezing system
the Talon could quite literally be put
on ice until their services are needed
after which they're frozen again now in
terms of risk wayne as a child he was
well versed in the history of the court
of owls while he had a malice a
possibility that the court existed his
father thomas wayne considered it to be
nonsense after spotting an owl roosting
in the Attic with a pile of bones
underneath several days before his
parents died bruce considered this to be
part of the nursery pertaining to
heeding the warning of the signs and so
following death of his parents bruce
considered the owl to have been a
warning from the court of owls
themselves and believed they were
responsible for his parents deaths and
following this he launched an
investigation into the court of owls
following every lead she could come
across that what's really interesting
about this is that where Bruce's
investigation has led him to discover
that there were multiple signs in the
city indicating the presence of the
court of owls
his search eventually led him to harbour
house the same place revealed to have
been the base of operations for the
court in 1891 however when he arrived he
found the house to be completely vacant
and
that rather than investigating using
logic he was investigating using his
emotions and went forward believing that
the court of owls was a myth now picking
up with 1/4 vowel story proper in my
videos we discussed that with Bruce
Wayne hosting a gala announcing his
intention to transform Gotham into an
ideal city by pouring money into the
poor neighborhoods his actions drew both
the attention of the court of owls and a
man named Lincoln March where Lyga was
running for the position of mayor and
sought to help Bruce the court of owls
taught to keep Bruce from changing the
status quo and possibly stripping them
of their influence in the city as City
the town after Bruce Wayne during a
meeting with Lincoln March brew survived
his fall from the top of the building by
landing on a gargoyle this combined with
Lincoln's story of how the court had
warned him not to run for mayor by
planting an owl on a pile of bones led
to Bruce acknowledging that maybe the
court was real drawing on his knowledge
of the superstitious nature of Allan
Wayne and his belief that the number
thirteen was bad luck Bruce Wayne
realized that a vallenwe'en followed
true with the superstition of the 13th
for being bad luck he would have sold
off the entire floor and all the
buildings that were commissioned safe
for a small space designed to contain
the bad luck investigating every one of
the buildings Bruce discovers that each
of the 13th floor rooms contains weapons
and items pertaining to the talons
however during his investigation
he's ambushed and captured by the Talon
and jumping to eight days later Bruce
Wayne woke up in the labyrinth of the
court of the owls with the story
depicting Batman losing his sanity due
to being confined to the labyrinth as
well as experiencing complete isolation
as part of his torture he's exposed to a
room that contains a camera and pictures
of every member of the Wayne family and
others who have died within the
labyrinth another aspect of Bruce
Wayne's torture as well as a
demonstration of his mind breaking is
the hallucination he has of his parents
believing them to be real
Bruce initially embraces them but
shortly after they begin to mutate and
turn into Al's which then attack burrs
and so with the Talon having been
stalking Bruce this entire time and
labyrinth he moves in for the kill
stabbing Batman through the back however
during their fight Batman is able to
overpower the Talon with everything he
has left and turning on the court while
we can't see them he states that he
knows everything there is to know about
the city of Gotham and that the
labyrinth is located near a river the
base of the owl statue in one of the
rooms is white marble and the
labyrinth is industrial marble which
contains potassium chlorate stealing one
of the filament plates from the camera
in the room of portraits he had nights
the white marble which destroys the base
of the owl statue
allowing him to escape to the cavern
below
and so picking up with night of the owls
which Wayne Bruce Wayne following his
escape from the labyrinth of the court
of the owls and his return to Wayne
Manor and due to the fact that his
torture involves spending days in
constant light after returning to Wayne
Manor
Bruce kept himself in almost complete
darkness while ever does what he can to
bring Bruce back to the world Bruce has
been completely consumed by his
experience in the labyrinth and the
knowledge that the court of owls exists
reading a bit between the lines here the
problem with the court of owls being
real is that it shows roost doesn't know
as much about the city of Gotham as he
thought he did and truth it wasn't as
though some kernel had been operating
behind the scenes for weeks and he
simply wasn't aware the court of owls
was an organization that had been
operating for hundreds of years not only
that he almost caught them as a child
but was unable to track them down
however while effort tries to comfort
Bruce Wayne Manor is met with the
arrival of several invaders what we
learned here is that the court of owls
had an army of talents and sent them
against Bruce Wayne within Wayne Manor
with Alfred in the Batcave monitoring
the situation and providing Bruce with
Intel he informs Bruce that the house is
surrounded with an army of talents and
however while he's speaking with Bruce
one of the town's makes their way into
the Batcave
with Bruce escaping his immediate
captors into one of the elevator shafts
what we learn is that the court of owls
doesn't seem to know that Bruce is
Batman when he arrives in the Batcave to
confront the Talon that had tried to
capture Alfred the Talon makes a
reference to the fact that Bruce Wayne
has secrets however before we get any
further clarification our word appears
pushing the giant penny over and pinning
the Talon to the ground as seizing his
arm and threatening to break it
Batman initially asked how many talons
are coming for him but when the Talon
refuses to answer
Batman strips him of his communication
device and taking refuge in a panic room
Alfred and Bruce access the drive where
they learn at the court of owls has sent
all of their talents into Gotham to kill
its most influential members in an
effort to seize control of the city and
so with the request of Batman alfred
puts out an alert to the entire bat
family from Tim Drake to Batgirl and an
effort to have everyone assist in saving
the targets on the courts list
following this Bruce Wayne dances
bat-armor instructing Alfred to seal the
armory and lower the temperature in the
Batcave to negative 50 degrees Batman
Begins to battle the talons because the
suit is able to withstand extreme heat
and extreme cold the goal of Batman is
to lower the temperature in the Batcave
to the point where the town's
effectively shut down however where the
talons able to crack portions of
Batman's armor the cold is able to seep
in leaving him vulnerable to the extreme
temperatures as the battle between the
talents of Batman continues the extreme
cold within the Batcave drives the bats
in the caverns to emerge giving Bruce
Wayne the distraction he needs to
overcome the talons and defeat them with
one remaining and making a run for the
doors Batman jumps into the Batmobile
and runs him over and so taking to the
streets of Gotham
Bruce has Alfred Ford lists of survivors
to his display what we learn is that of
all the people who head up Gotham City
or are in some capacity influential the
only two individuals left are lincoln
March and Jeremiah Arkham the head of
Arkham Asylum with Dick Grayson heading
to Arkham Batman travels to the offices
of Lincoln March after arriving and
opening the door
Batman's actually shot by Lincoln
however after speaking with him
Lincoln appears to have thought that
Batman was a talent but also seems to
have been mortally wounded the city that
he knows Batman is friends with Bruce
Wayne and Lincoln passes Batman a note
stating that Bruce your continuous dream
to revitalize Gotham into something
great and so with Lincoln dying from his
injuries Batman reveals to Alfred that
the note contains the names of the court
of the owl's members which Batman
intends to pursue in order to bring the
organization to an end in from here we
jump to a building called powers hotel
ran by Joseph Emery at powers one of the
most influential families in Gotham the
hotel is kept under intense security
with no one entering or leaving without
direct permission for the powers family
themselves what we find though is that
as Maria powers prepares to leave she's
actually confronted by Bruce Wayne
revealing that he had broken into the
hotel and taken the alla' mask of Maria
her response is that while Batman
believes that he has the upper hand here
the truth is that the court of owls is
an international organization and that
Bruce Wayne will never truly win out
however the planet Batman is revealed
after he leaves when Alfred states that
Maria is calling her husband
while the call is coded and they're
unable to trace it Alfred is able to
located dead zone within Gotham City
where the cell reception is completely
blocked as he prepares to tell Batman
its location
Batman realizes that the location of
Joseph's powers is the Harbor House club
the same location he had tracked down as
a kid after traveling to the building
that man enters a meeting room in the
attic where he learns that all of the
members of the Court of the Owls are
apparently dead by suicide and so where
the town was defeated by the rest of the
bat family and the core completely gone
Batman heads back to Wayne Manor in
picking up several weeks later we
learned that Bruce Wayne has been
struggling with the fact that the deaths
of the court members simply don't make
any sense to him with the group existing
internationally it would have made more
sense for them to vacate Gotham regroup
and then come back in force in addition
to this someone has apparently been
siphoning money from all their accounts
following their deaths leading Bruce
Wayne to believe that even if the court
members have their own agenda
someone was simply pulling the strings
while alpha tries to assuage Bruce's
belief that treachery is afoot he also
states that Bruce Wayne's issue was most
likely due to the fact that his pursuit
of the court of owls goes back to the
death of his parents where initially he
found nothing to link them to his
parents death and tracking them down now
with more experience coupled with their
identities having been revealed might
shed some light on his parents murders
however as a to prepare for a previously
scheduled meeting Bruce Wayne seems to
have figured everything out and leaves
transitioning to a place called the
Willow Wood home for children Bruce
Wayne tells us that the hospital served
as a place for kids suffering from
mental illnesses and neurological
disorders what he also says is that 18
years prior the hospital shut down when
a sinkhole
opened beneath the orderlies quarters
following the panic and the arrival of
emergency and news crews the city
learned that the children in Willa wood
suffered abuses at the hands of the
staff including neglect with the
children being taken away and the staff
arrested the building was closed down
and now serves as a place where kids
spend the night on dares and so
venturing further into the hospital
Batman has suddenly seized by a
booby-trap was speaking to a man in the
shadows a full explanation of the events
pertained to the court of the owls and
the night of the owls is given to us
what we're told is that this man is not
linked in March and instead claims to be
Thomas Wayne jr. the brother of Bruce
Wayne
as is explained when Bruce Wayne and
Thomas Wayne jr. previously met at Wayne
Manor and the front of the portrait of
Bruce Wayne's parents
Thomas had told Bruce's story about how
his parents had died in a car crash and
in the debris was a pen in the form of a
misshapen heart to belong to his mother
and was kept in her memory but when
Bruce Wayne was at Wayne Manor speaking
with Alfred while looking at the
portrait of his mother he realized that
when Lincoln was telling him about the
accident
he stole the idea of the heart-shaped
pin and included it into his story
providing more backstory here in the
midst of their battle across the city
what we're told is that when Bruce was
three years old Martha Wayne had been
pregnant with Thomas but was involved in
a car crash going into labor early
Thomas Wayne jr. was revealed to have
suffered injuries while in the womb and
was placed in Willow Wood which had been
a premier Children's Hospital at the
time and was financed by Thomas Wayne
senior and Martha Wayne however when
they died Willa wood was no longer being
funded by the Wayne's and became the
property of the city and all evidence
that Thomas was their son went with him
leaving him an orphan and following this
Thomas Wayne jr. was taken and by the
court of owls for the purpose of
replacing Bruce Wayne when the events of
Infinite Crisis happened and Bruce Wayne
was thrown into the past the court had
assumed that he died and made their move
to introduce Thomas Wayne as Bruce's
replacement in the city of Gotham
but when Bruce Wayne returned the courts
plans were basically foiled and coming
up with the identity of Lincoln March
Thomas Wayne jr. was introduced as a
distraction for Bruce Wayne while the
court implemented their plans to seize
control of Gotham by removing all of
those in control
however because Bruce was closing in on
the truth and would have figured out who
Thomas Wayne was eventually the court
had one of the town's assassinate Thomas
because he had previously consumed the
serum that allows the talents to come
back to life Thomas survived the
assassination and in turn poisoned the
court following the emergency session
called by Maria powers after her
encounter with Batman
and so as the story begins to come to a
close with the battle raging on between
Batman and Thomas Wayne jr. Thomas fires
several explosive devices into the walls
of the tower with the intention of
destroying both himself and Batman
overpowering Thomas as the bombs go off
Batman flees the tower jumping to safety
but because Thomas Wayne jr. had the
serum in his body allowing him to
regenerate and because the only way to
shut down his howl and was to expose
them to extreme cold
Batman's conversation with Dick Grayson
following these events leave him with a
question as to whether or not Thomas
Wayne is really his brother whether he
survived the explosion and whether or
not the court of owls will ever return
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and the next time
we do a Batman story we will do death of
the family what that being said I will
catch you guys on him purse